Amazon turns heads by selecting New York
and Washington DC as its new second
headquarters the Florida recount efforts
get uglier and president Trump goes
after the French is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
now listen well I love mocking the
French as much as the next guy
it's always more entertaining when
President Trump does it we'll get to
that in just a second Plus Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez
now finally has a platform to stand on
the platform is she hates Amazon which
is a weird platform but we'll get to all
of that in just a second first let's
talk about keeping your home safer today
over a million people use the amazing
ring video doorbell to help protect
their homes ring knows home security
begins at the front door it doesn't end
there so now they are extending that
same level of security to the rest of
your home with the ring flood like him
I'm somebody takes security incredibly
seriously particularly when I look out
at the political domain and I see an
Tifa descending on Tucker Carlson's home
and that's one of the reasons why I have
great security at my house and that
security includes ring ring has that
amazing doorbell that allows me when I'm
3,000 miles away to see exactly who is
ringing the doorbell at my house very
often burglars will ring the doorbell at
your house before they actually robbed
you to make sure that you're not home
well they don't know you're not home if
you're picking up the phone and you can
check to see who exactly is at your
front door also right now the floodlight
camp is a motion-activated camera and
floodlight that connects right to your
phone with HD video and two-way audio
that lets you know the moment anyone
steps on your property you can see it
and speak to visitors you can even set
off an alarm directly from your phone
with rings floodlight Kim when things go
bump in the night you will immediately
know what it is whether you're home or
away the ring floodlight hem lets you
keep an eye on your home right now save
up to one hundred and fifty bucks off a
ring of security kit when you go to ring
calm / Ben that's ring.com
/ Ben again is a great service ring calm
/ Ben and save up to one hundred and
fifty dollars off a ring of security kit
ok so a lot to get to today we begin
today with the announcement by Amazon
that they have found their next
headquarters - now there is a big year
long search for where they were going to
locate their second headquarters one of
the reasons nobody will talk about that
they are trying to start a second
headquarters is because the business
climate in Seattle has really gone south
Amazon is not the first company based in
Seattle that has started creating
headquarters outside Seattle Boeing
famously did this a couple of years ago
when
went down to South Carolina with one of
their latest plants because doing
business in Seattle was too expensive
that thanks to leftist governments well
Amazon had announced like a year ago
that they were going to open up a second
headquarters now they've decided that
they're going to open a second and third
headquarters they're gonna split that
second headquarters are they going to
locate it in a distressed town in Ohio
or Pennsylvania are they going to
restart industry in a part of the
country where industry has been falling
away now of course not they're going to
locate it in New York and Washington DC
so after all was said and done they're
locating this thing in Crystal City
which is basically a bunch of cement
buildings just out of DC and they're
going to be locating it in Queens which
happens to be the home district of you
guessed it Alexandria okasha cortes
they've decided to move into she
Guevara's backyard so that's that's very
exciting stuff according to The Wall
Street Journal New York City in Northern
Virginia will be the homes for Amazon's
second and third headquarters according
to people familiar with the matter
ending a more than year-long public
contest that started with 238 candidates
and ended with a surprise split of its
so-called HQ - in other words they gave
the runaround to 240 cities then picked
the two cities everyone figured they
would locate in who won nearest to
legislative power and the one nearest to
financial power in New York City and
Washington DC the imminent announcement
is expected today according to people
other cities that may also receive a
major cite some of the people said so
the second headquarters is divided
evenly between New York's Long Island
City and Arlington County's Crystal City
neighborhoods which are both located
directly across from major city centers
they're saying there will be
approximately 25,000 employees in each
location it is unclear exactly what the
deal was
Amazon was sort of pitching this
publicly so the people could be making
overtures to them tax breaks tax
loopholes subsidies and it's not clear
what either city did Crystal City or New
York City did to draw Amazon there
suffice it to say I'm not in favor of
business subsidies from government I
don't think taxpayers should be
subsidizing businesses just as I don't
think the businesses should being taking
advantage of tax payers with all of that
said what really should be happening is
all the tax breaks available to major
corporations should be available to
every business in a particular area if
New York thinks it's drawing business by
paying off Amazon
wouldn't it be drawing more business by
lowering the
trait on all the businesses already in
New York wouldn't that be a good way to
draw more business to New York it's
amazing how the logic seems to go out
the window when it comes to leftist
governance in major cities they're
willing to offer all sorts of goodies
and incentives and chocolate sweets to
various companies to come in and they
will cherry pick the companies they want
to come in but they won't lower the
overall tax rate and regulatory burden
so that more businesses will just enter
naturally in any case New York City
Mayor Bill DeBlasio he's a communist
discuss the Amazon zeal Monday night
during his weekly television appearance
although he didn't confirm that the city
had been officially selected he was
hopeful that HQ would come to New York
City he said we're talking about the
single biggest economic deal development
deal in the history of New York City
again if you really want to make an
economic development deal for New York
City you just got rid of a lot of the
taxes and regulations and rent controls
and all of the idiotic policies bill de
blasio has followed and have alienated a
lot of businesses from New York City and
to other places in the country Amazon is
also moving to New York in order to face
up against Google because Google is also
looking to expand into the city
apparently alphabet Inc which is Google
is going to add office space for more
than 12,000 new workers which is an
amount nearly double the search giant's
current staffing in the city Amazon had
recently been in late stage negotiations
with several locations including New
York Crystal City and Dallas aside from
the GHQ two decisions Amazon may also
announce other cities have won big
projects one of the reasons by the way
that Amazon is moving to Crystal City is
because it is number one close to DC and
number two it's close to Jeff Bezos
who's the founder of Amazon and has his
house over there so in sheer size and
proximity to Washington Reagan National
Airport metro stops another
transportation Crystal City was an
attractive prospect for him Amazon's
ambitious the second at headquarters
plans also it is largely in the hands of
a single developer which means that they
can grab as much real estate as they
want there's some bad traffic over there
the real reason they're moving there is
highly educated populations access to
capital access to regulation regulatory
control regulatory capture one of the
things that people need to know about
big business is that big business and
capitalism are not identical big
businesses take advantage of whatever
profit there is to be had even at the
hands of the government they are not shy
about going to the government for help
and this is a case in point of Amazon
doing
that it's also a case in point of you
know Amazon's been doing that with
regard to food stamps for example it's
been a lot of talk about how many folks
work for Amazon are on food stamps and
people blame Amazon for that well the
reason that Amazon can pay those people
low wages is because food stamps are
available and overall the RIP on Amazon
that Amazon is a terrible terrible
employer is simply not true well
regardless it so so my general points
are to one when business comes to a city
it is good for the city to when
businesses come to a city because the
city is paying the business to come to
the city that is ripping off taxpayers
both of these points can be true at once
Alexander Ocasio courts has in New York
is very very upset about Amazon moving
into our city for one good reason and
for mostly bad reason so here is what
she tweeted out today our favorite
Congress person who thinks that I can't
call her she says we've been getting
calls and outreach from Queens residents
all day about this the community's
response outraged so first of all I
really really doubt that the response of
Queens to a massive company moving into
Queens and bringing 25,000 jobs was
outrage I can't name the number of
cities that like really I don't think
any cities exist where people are deeply
deeply outraged overall about major
companies moving into their midst
except for the fact that there are a
certain group of people or afraid they
won't get jobs from Amazon and are
afraid that upward pressures in housing
and gentrification are gonna push them
out I assume those are the people that
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez is talking about
and the reason that all of that is
happening is specifically because of
policies that Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
pushes the policies that she pushes
include rent control they include wage
subsidies they include heavy regulations
business all of these policies are
likely to result in less employment in
the area and upward pressure on rents
how do we know this because Amazon's
original headquarters in Seattle has
been pressured by just those things
Seattle recently tried to pass a head
tax on Amazon trying to tax them for
every employee in the city
which is one of the reasons why Amazon
is fleeing to other parts of the country
or at least diversifying its its labor
base across other parts of the country
the reason there's been upward rent
pressure in Seattle is because of
serious restrictions on the sort of
housing that people can build you know
you think developer
wouldn't want to build and redevelop in
Queens to build new housing as there's
upward pressure of course they would
right supply would then meet demand but
New York supply can't meets a man
because it's almost impossible to build
anything there and because heavy rent
control regulations have prevented
everyone from being able to rent at
market prices which means that people
are being forced out of their apartments
as apartment owners have started to have
it have started to figure out ways to
toss people out rent control is
legitimately the worst policy that you
can pursue in an area with upward rent
pressure and new employees here's what
Alexandra of cosmic winds has tweets
though she says the problem is not all
the regulation the problem is not even
tax subsidies the problem is Amazon
Amazon is evil how do we know Amazon is
evil because it's a company and
companies are bad according to Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez whose entire employment
history includes working at a bar
part-time I guess that's and who has by
age 29 not saved enough money to be able
to afford two months of rent in
Washington DC an expectation of a
six-figure salary from the federal
government here's what she tweeted out
Amazon is a billion dollar company the
idea that it will receive hundreds of
millions of dollars in tax breaks at a
time when our subway is crumbling our
communities need more investment not
less is extremely concerning to
residents here well number one this is
the part where I say she's sort of half
right she's right that Amazon should not
be getting all sorts of tax breaks
everybody in New York should be getting
all sorts of tax breaks she's wrong here
though when she suggests that what we
really need is more tax dollars poured
into the MTA fifteen billion dollars a
year is spent on the MTA more than the
entire GDP of 70 counties in the United
States Haley the MTA is not bankrupt
because it's lacking tax dollars the MTA
is bankrupt
because people are not actually paying
what it costs to ride the subway and
every time there's a proposal to raise
the subway fee in New York City
everybody cries about it and then they
just tossed more taxpayer dollars at it
and then it doesn't get solved and the
fact is that the MTA requires higher
higher subway fees and that's just the
reality of the situation but she
continues and here's where it gets
really bad for Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
who doesn't understand free markets or
even want to understand free markets she
says when we talk about bringing jobs to
the community we need to dig deep and
here we get into the full-on socialists
not democratic
socialist socialist Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez who wants to control the means of
production because I want a part-time
bartender figuring out how Amazon a
billion-dollar company ought to run its
business a company by the way with
600,000 employees globally
I want Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
determining how exactly Amazon can
maintain profit and also ensure
employment she says when we talk about
bringing jobs to the community we need
to dig deep has the company promised to
hire in the existing community well in
this particular case yes I mean they're
not shipping and a bunch of people from
Portland what's the quality of jobs and
how many are promised are these jobs low
wage or high wage are there benefits can
people collectively bargain okay
number one the company is gonna hire
precisely the number of people that it
needs to fill particular jobs because
this is how markets work as for the idea
that Amazon is gonna unionize Amazon is
not going to tolerate unions because the
Amazon does not need to tolerate unions
Amazon again employs hundreds of
thousands of people and if they were to
raise the labor rates presumably they
would also lay some of those people off
this is what happens whenever there is a
government enforced attempt to raise
wages there's a backlash in terms of
employment in a second I'm going to
explain why Alexandra Oh Cosmo Cortes is
so wrong here and why unfortunately she
is is her her particular perspective on
what government should do with business
is not restricted to one side of the
aisle well we'll talk about that in just
one second first let's talk about what
you would do in case of disaster so over
where I live in Los Angeles right now
there are these major wildfires they've
caused people to have to evacuate their
homes some folks can't get out to the
market some people don't have access to
all the other supplies that they need
well if you were in the path of a
disaster you would certainly be happy to
know that you had all of the supplies
necessary in order to survive and that's
why you need my Patriot supply you need
a plan for food storage and water
filtration when emergencies strike
protection from disaster survival tools
get those items and my Patriot supply my
team here uses them and you should too
they've helped over a million
hardworking Americans become more
self-reliant my Patriot supply sells
hundreds of items including emergency
food kits gravity-powered water
filtration systems and my Patriot
supply.com
that's my Patriot supply comm could be
an earthquake a cyber attack that
freezes the banking system could be a
disaster the Trust's down the power grid
there are plenty of bad eventualities
that you could think of
and a lot of them actually happen I mean
how many of you have experienced in sort
of natural disaster certainly we in
California have for all these
emergencies and more get your supplies
to be more self-reliant and my Patriots
apply calm no more rushing to find empty
store shelves because you're too late do
it now so you're prepared my Patriot
supply calm that's my Patriot supply.com
okay so Alexandre Ocasio Cortez again
she tweets that she wants to know what
kind of jobs are gonna be created by
Amazon and this has been the the great
sort of pitch that have been made by
people like Bernie Sanders about Amazon
oh they're not paying their workers
enough hey here is the reality of the
situation
Amazon created a hundred and thirty
thousand new jobs last year alone the
folks who are on food stamps are mainly
part-time workers and many of them a
huge number of them are opting to work
part-time in the United States the
average hourly wage for a full-time
associate in their fulfillment centers
including cash stocking incentive
bonuses is over fifteen dollars an hour
before overtime in addition to a full
benefits package including health vision
and dental insurance retirement generous
parental leave and skills training for
in-demand jobs through their career
choice program which has 16,000
participants according to Amazon so the
idea that Amazon is just creating a
bunch of crap jobs this is the new
argument that you saw a lot of people
make about Walmart for years it was not
true about Walmart and it is not true
about Amazon either that's not stopping
Alexandre or kasnia Cortez from mouthing
off as though she knows what she's
talking about when it comes to business
she says displacement is not community
development so the idea is the Amazon is
coming in and all these people are gonna
come in with them and people are going
to be displaced again residential
displacement is a result of rent control
and prevention of developers from
actually building new buildings and new
rental units that is how you honestly
you want to make sure that people can't
afford to live in an area ensure that
there can only be a set number of units
for a larger number of people this
creates upward price pressure it's this
is basic econ 101 Alexander Ocasio
Cortez doesn't understand it sunny bunch
over at the Washington Examiner hello
and the Weekly Standard yeah in a very
funny line about this he said you know
if she's so worried about displacement
you know we could do we create a company
town like we call it prime town and in
prime town all the workers would have to
live in prime town they'd have to live
in the area and they would actually have
to spend part of their paycheck with
prime
town and they would be given company
scrip to spend on various products and
all of the services would be provided by
that company and nothing bad would ever
happen right if this idea sounds good to
you then you should think about every
coal company in the 1930s and 40s that
did have these company towns and which
ended up being wildly restrictive and
preventing people from living free lives
you can't have it both ways if you want
control from the top or you don't want
control from the top
more on this in in just one second so
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez didn't stop
there she ripped on Amazon's job quality
now that Amazon is moving to New York
City into Queens because I'm sure what
Amazon really wanted was to be harassed
by Alexandra or kasnia Cortez when they
decided to move to Queens she worked on
job quality she ripped on on
displacement she says we need to focus
on good health care living wages
affordable Reds corporations that offer
none of those things should be met with
skepticism okay well number one a
corporation that does not offer a living
wage is not in business for very long
because all of its employees are dead
yeah it does not mean that all of them
all employers are paying what they
should be pay they're paying what the
market will bear and if people don't
want to work for those companies we live
in a free country they don't have to
it's not the job of a company to provide
affordable rent that is the job of the
government to get out of the way and
she's talked about good health care I
wasn't aware that it's Amazon's job to
provide good health care it is their job
to provide the incentives that allow
people to work for them including health
insurance if necessary she does it's
possible to establish economic
partnerships with real opportunities for
working families instead of a race to
the bottom competition if you think that
it's a race to the bottom competition to
bring in a company that has twenty five
thousand employees in your area I don't
know what to tell you she also by the
way says investing in luxury condos is
not the same thing as investing in
people and Families well investing in
condos is the same thing as investing in
people and families because guess who
lives in the condos you I mean
legitimately this is a stupid point
investing in new rental units is one of
the ways that you provide housing to
people in fact it is the chief way the
provide housing to people and you know
who occupies those luxury condos all of
the rich people who otherwise would be
living in rent controlled hovels in
Queens says shuffling working-class
people out of a community does not
improve their quality of life again the
only reason that those people would be
shuffled out of the community is
regulation and finally she concludes
lastly this isn't just about one company
or one headquarters it's about the cost
of living corpse paying their fair share
etc assuming corpus means corporations
it's not about picking a fight either I
was elected to advocate for our
community's interests and they've
requested clearly to voice their
concerns okay well what's your proposal
to ban Amazon to force Amazon to pay
higher taxes again so they can take all
those jobs and leave right to ensure
that Amazon pays for affordable housing
by presumably using the power of
government to cram down on them it's
amazing how how folks who are in favor
of social control of the means of
production are suddenly shocked when all
of that turns out to be a giant failure
you can't have it both ways either you
want your area to get nicer which
includes bringing in businesses that
bring with them jobs and upward mobility
and indeed upward rent pressures or you
can sit there and you can talk about how
you're helping your community when
you're actually not helping your
community is it's it's truly amazing
when folks suggest that gentrification
is terrible for a community and then
they decry that no jobs are coming to
the community you can't have it both
ways if jobs come to the community it's
because crime rates have gone down and
because people are moving in who are
trying to work at those companies and
because economic pressures are moving
rents up all those things come as a
basket there is no world in which rents
stay the same with high regulations and
yet more jobs come into the neighborhood
that has never happened in human history
because it violates every basic law of
human behavior and economics it is
amazing though to watch the conflict
between Alexandra Ocasio cortes and Bill
de Blasio bill de blasio of course
understands that he has to subsidize
Amazon to come into New York City in
order to overcome the burden of having
to work with places like Queens with all
of its regulatory with all these
regulatory burdens now the fact is that
people like Alexandria Ocasio Cortez and
Bernie Sanders they like to talk about
the Nordic countries and how the Nordic
countries are wonderful places to live
you know the Nordic countries don't do
tax their businesses at exorbitant rates
in the Nordic countries the reason that
their economies are able to work okay is
because their economies are largely
based on low business regulation and low
cost of doing business in those states
where Norway and Denmark and Sweden
where all those countries go off the
rails when it comes to
domestic tax rates and Alexander are
cosmic Court has presumably wants those
two this is what she'll never tell you
what Bernie Sanders will never tell you
if she wants if you want to pay for
Alexandra Ocasio cortezes program it's
not enough for her just to glom on to
Amazon and take away the profit margin
in the end she's going to need to go to
people who are middle class in the
United States and take away all their
money to the tax rates in places like
Denmark are 60% for people making above
50 60 grand a year and they're going to
tell you that she's never gonna tell you
that because what she wants is to be
able to tell you you can have everything
you can have low tax rates as a middle
class person and you don't have to move
out of the rent controlled apartment and
you can have a job from Amazon that is
not the way any of this works okay in
just a second I want to talk to you
about Jim Acosta and CNN who are now
suing President Trump also want to talk
about a situation that has broken out in
the Gaza Strip in Israel few people are
talking about it but you only hear about
it when Israel actually fights back
because that's the way this works first
however let's talk about your back
comfort so when you got a back problem
it's the worst thing in the world I've
had my back seized up before after
working out I've had a sore back before
I've had situations where I've had to
lie on just a flat hardwood floor it's
really difficult when got a back problem
to deal with it and that's why you might
need Teeter the teeter inversion table
is just fantastic with the teeter
inversion table you use gravity and your
own body weights decompress your spine
relieve pressure on your discs and
surrounding nerves my personal trainer
Derek he's a guy who has right now some
pretty severe back problems he's been
using the teeter inversion table and he
tells me it's really been helping it
makes him feel stretched out makes him
feel sort of elongated and it elongate
the spine makes it makes him feel more
comfortable and I mean this is a guy
who's been in serious pain for a while
decompressing on a teeter inversion
table for a few minutes a day is a
terrific addition to anyone's daily
routine to maintain a healthy spine and
an active lifestyle without the pain I
feel really good when I got off the
teeter inversion table I got one in my
house it decompresses the spine and it's
good for my shoulders as well they're
offering a great deal right now just for
my listeners for a limited time you can
get the brand-new 2019 teeter fit spine
inversion table model with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots so you can invert at home or take
the boots with you to the gym teeter
inversion tables have thousands of
reviews on amazon they are rated at 4.6
stars and that's for a reason with this
deal you get 150
Soph when you go to Teeter dot-com / Ben
you also get free shipping free returns
a 60 day money back guarantee so you
really have nothing to lose
remember you can only get that new 2019
Teeter Fitz find inversion table plus a
free pair of gravity boots by going to
teeter comm slash Ben that's te e ter
dot-com slash Ben go check it out right
now I've done my homework this is the
best inversion table on the market go
check it out right now Teeter calm slash
Ben oh yeah meanwhile the great battle
of our time between Jim Acosta and
Donald Trump continues because this is
just what the country needs this is what
the country is cNN has now sued
president Trump demanding the return of
Jim Acosta to the White House because
presumably he has some sort of right to
be in the White House now it is true the
federal government is not allowed to
engage in viewpoint discrimination so
the federal government cannot just
decide that they don't want somebody
covering the White House because they
don't like the guy's viewpoint right
that would be a violation of certain
basic First Amendment precepts and
there's an arguments we made that
President Trump is doing that with your
my costume that's not really what's
happening with Jim Acosta right because
the fact is 95% of the press room hates
President Trump
95% of the press room agrees with Jim
Acosta and Trump isn't banning any of
those people in reality president Trump
and Jim Acosta because Jim Acosta would
not give up his microphone and instead
insistent on holding his microphone
overriding all the other reporters and
yelling at the President of the United
States in the middle of a press
conference CNN is suing anyway they're
suing the Trump administration demanding
that Acosta's press credentials to cover
the White House be returned the
administration revoked them last week
obviously the lawsuit was filed Tuesday
in Washington DC district court CNN
claims the revocation of Acosta's press
pass violates the constitutional rights
to freedom of the press and due process
CNN is asking for an immediate
restraining order to return Acosta to
the White House there's no immediate
comment from the administration this
seems like a sort of bizarre argument
again because he did violate certain
basic rules of the press room when the
White House suspended him and said that
it did so because he placed his hands on
an intern who was trying to take the
microphone from him
really it was in my opinion incidental
contact but CNN is making the claim that
this is really about the president
doesn't like Acosta and so he doesn't
want to class in there again I think
that's a weak argument president Trump
hates every member of the press that he
can find
including April Ryan who has not had a
press pass revoked in the White House so
there there are plenty of people in the
White House press room who president
Trump cannot stand all those people are
still attending every single day so the
claim by CNN that this is simply about
Trump doesn't like Acosta seems
far-fetched to me I don't buy it
it meanwhile in other news it must be
pointed out that there are hundreds of
rockets a day that are now falling on
Israel I'm getting emails from people
videos from people who are legitimately
living in their basements they're living
in bomb shelters right now across Israel
because of hundreds of rockets that are
descending from the Gaza Strip before
you say this is because of the quote
unquote about occupation recognized that
for 12 years Israel has not been present
in the Gaza Strip the Gaza Strip is run
by a terrorist group called Hamas and
that terrorist group has routinely used
the Gaza Strip as a staging point for
attacks on Israelis they've built terror
tunnels to try and kidnap Israelis
they've tried to breach the border in
order to invade Israeli land they burn
thousands of acres of Israeli lands with
with kites that have incendiaries
attached to them and balloons they have
incendiaries attached to them and now
they're firing rockets randomly into
civilian areas you're not seeing this
covered in the media because the media
don't care when Jews get killed in
Israel and the media don't care about
that the media pretend to care about
anti-semitism in a serious way when Jews
get killed in Pittsburgh because then
they can try and blame President Trump
and they can talk about right-wing
anti-semitism which is a brand of
anti-semitism does exist when it comes
to radical Muslim anti-semitism they go
completely silent for the same reason
that President Obama once said about a
radical Islamist attack on a kosher
supermarket in France that it was random
it wasn't an system it was a random
attack a the idea that it is not the
same anti-semitism that drives Hamas
attacks on Israeli civilians as drives
attacks on a show in Pittsburgh is a
bunch of crap it is simply nonsense and
what you're going to see from the press
is nothing about the hundreds of rockets
falling into the civilian areas of a
democratic ally of the United States
until Israel fights back at which point
you're going to see the press say Mikey
Israel strikes the poor aquiver in
Palestinian population and all the
Palestinians have to do in the Gaza
Strip is elect a government that is not
come us all they have to do is elect a
government that wants to make peace with
Israel and then open up their markets
and the capital would come flowing in
Gaza has natural
nice seaside territory but they're not
going to do that because there's an
ideological and ideological commitments
the destruction of Israel and the murder
of Jews these Rockets are not directed
at military installations this is not a
war this is an attack on a civilian
population very deliberately and the
media will ignore it up till the point
when Israel fights back at which point
they will blame the Jews that is in and
of itself an aspect of leftist
anti-semitism that manifests itself
every time the media covered the
conflict between Israel and the
Palestinian Authority and Hamas and
Islamic Jihad every time that conflict
breaks out the media suggests that
Israel is at the top of the of the power
hierarchy and therefore Hamas is attacks
on Israel are not really anti-semitic
it's really about power relationships
and this is how they cover for radical
Muslim anti-semitism but what we are
watching right now schools being hit
bakeries being hit and there's there's
52 Israelis who have gone to hospitals
thanks to bombs randomly falling in
their midst again hundreds of rockets
being shot every day I mean this is the
worst it's been in Israel since the 2014
Gaza war it's really been quite awful
over there you can see the videos online
that will never be covered by the
mainstream media there's a pretty
heartbreaking video of a dog that had
been that had been fatally wounded by a
rocket that just fell into a civilian
area now all of this again will be
ignored by the global media up until the
point at which Israel starts to defend
itself at which point Israel will be
condemned for disproportionate force and
all of the people on the on the left
like the J streets of the world will
condemn Israel at that point demonstrate
exactly what it is that they are which
is a bunch of anti-semitic enablers if
you're enabling all of this then you are
then you're part of the problem and
meanwhile in other news over in Florida
the recount process continues to be a
complete crap tornado it's a disaster
according to mark Caputo over at
Politico Broward election chief is
likely to be forced from office by Rick
Scott and Ron de Santos that makes
perfect sense that makes perfect sense
because again she's awful at her job her
name is Brenda Snipes
here's what Marc Caputo writes counting
all awful votes destroying ballots
sunshine law violations busted deadlines
so many controversies have bedeviled
Broward County election supervisor
Brenda Snipes culminating in her off
his troubles in the aftermath of
Florida's chaotic 2018 elections that
her days in office are now numbered
insiders and lawmakers say she was bound
by law to start turning in election
results within 24 hours of the of the
actual election taking place instead it
took her a week and then she was
suddenly discovering ballots coming in
out of nowhere now that doesn't
necessarily mean election fraud took
place but one of the reasons that you
want to have these laws on the books in
the first place is to fully ensure that
election fraud does not take place right
this is one of the things that we
actually care about in the United States
it's quite important that we have these
laws on the books we want the no even
appearance of impropriety that's why we
have sunshine laws that's why we have
reporting obligations retinas tonight
blew through all of those the difference
between the right and the left on this
issue is the let's keep saying well we
just want all the votes counted no you
want all of the votes counted including
illegal votes the right wants only legal
votes counted and according to the
process of law that's a real
differentiation and it is amusing to
watch the positions flip-flop when it
comes to Florida and Georgia in Georgia
there are some election problems and
suddenly the Democrats are saying that
election fraud took place and that they
lost there because of election fraud but
when Republicans say that they're
worried about election fraud in Florida
then all of a sudden it's the end of the
Republic it's the end of the world when
Republicans talk about the possibility
of election fraud in Florida when
Democrats talk about election fraud in
Georgia then all of a sudden it's
perfectly legitimate when Democrats talk
about how Trump's told the election
because of the Russians perfectly
legitimate not a threat to the democracy
in any way when Republicans talk about
an actual official Brenda Snipes
who has a history of destroying ballots
and counting on lawful votes when they
talk about maybe that's a problem then
all of a sudden they're dealin amaizing
election results truly amazing we'll
discuss that more in just one second but
first let's talk about how you can
invest better Robin Hood it's an
investing app that lets you buy it and
sell stocks ETFs options and Kryptos all
commission-free they strive to make
Financial Services work for everyone not
just wealthy folks it's a non
intimidating way for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence folks in our office
use Robin Hood and they've shown me how
it works it is clear and it is easy to
use they've easy to understand charts
market data you can place a trade in
just four taps on your smart phone all
so unless you've used stock collections
like 100 most popular or sectors like
entertainment in social media they the
analyst ratings a buy hold sell for
every single stock and their Commission
fee is that there are none right there
there are no commission fees other
brokerages charge up to 10 bucks for
every trade but with Robin Hood you
trade stocks and you keep all of the
profits this is a the best way to learn
the stock market is simply by
participating in the stock market you
can do that by using Robin Hood Robin
Hood right now is giving my listener as
a free stock like Apple Ford or sprint
to help build your portfolio right now
sign up at Shapiro Robin Hood calm
that's Shapiro
Robin Hood calm go check it out it's
super user-friendly it's really easy and
for a lot of my young listeners who are
interested in getting into the stock
market it's a great introduction to the
stock market Shapiro dot Robin Hood comm
go check it out right now okay well I
have a lot more to say on the Florida
situation plus I want to talk to you
about the 2020 race and we're Democrats
B could be in danger of making a very
large mistake plus Michelle Obama made a
pretty absurd comment that I want to
talk about in just a second but for all
of that you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire comm and subscribe for $9.99
a month you can get a subscription to
daily wire you get the rest of this show
you get the rest of the Andrew Klavan
show you get the rest of Michael
Knowles's show you also get early access
to another Kingdom don't miss the next
chapter of another Kingdom which is our
fictional series it's really produced up
it's performed by the execrable Michael
moles is a better actor than he is a
human today subscribers have exclusive
access to episode 7 the secret of horror
mansion also known as Hillary Clinton's
Chappaqua home if you're not a
subscriber you can listen to the entire
episode on Friday via YouTube and
SoundCloud only subscribers that get to
watch the full show so go check that out
right now all sorts of great goodies
that you get when you become a
subscriber also you got this the very
greatest in beverage vessels leftist
here is hot or cold tumbler I have used
it's on the road invisibility function
so does know it is it is clothed the
cloaking device has been activated you
can't see it right now but it is that
good also just a reminder if you happen
to be in Columbus Ohio tonight I am
speaking at the Ohio State University at
7:00 p.m. Eastern
you can watch me dismantle the left both
in person and online at Yap dot org
slash live we are streaming it live at
yah org slash live I hope to see you
there so again lots of goodies please
subscribe it always helps us out and go
over to YouTube or iTunes and subscribe
leave us a review of her in iTunes it
helps us with the iTunes rankings
check us out over there we're the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so again Brenda Snipes is losing support
from her fellow Democrats and she faces
the likelihood of a suspension by
Governor Rick Scott or Rhonda Santos
that makes perfect sense again she's
been awful at her job Senator Marco
Rubio said this is not just the most
troubled elections office in the state
it's the most troubled elections office
in the nation she has shown brendensen
ID she's incapable of conducting a large
important election in a way that
inspires public confidence and trust
she's been found with destroyed ballots
and violation of the law opened absentee
ballots early and violation of law
ms printed ballots have gone out and
naturally she's so incompetent that
Democrats are trying to blame
Republicans at this point Andrea
Mitchell on MSNBC falsely tried to claim
that Brenda Snipes was a Republican
Brenda Snipes in Broward County is a
Republican appointed by former governor
then Governor Jeb Bush
so she was put in by a Republican
governor after the mess that we all
remember from to 2000 and she's hardly a
democratic official no she's a
democratic official she was in fact a
democratic official she was replaced on
the Broward County Elections board by
former Governor Jeb Bush when her
predecessor was also terrible she's a
Democrat she's a registered Democrat she
went on to win four elections to cement
her hold on the heavily Democratic
County's election machinery so yes she's
a Democrat trying to blame it on the
Republicans is not exactly going to help
none of this is is good for the state of
the nation when it comes to elections
and by the way and for all the folks in
the media who keep claiming that
Republicans are throwing elections in
sit out I will remind them that they
have been doing this since Donald Trump
won election in 2016 I will also remind
them that over in Arizona where martha
mcsalley sadly lost her election bid
against insane person Kyrsten Sinema
she has not claimed elections fraud in
any way shape or form she's not claims
elections impropriety a recount happened
she lost the recount and she accepted
the results of the recount because there
wasn't this sort of elections
impropriety this is not stopping
Democrats and folks in the media from
claiming that Republicans are trying to
overthrow democracy by calling for
people to actually abide by the law in
Florida David Leonhart an opinion
columnist over at The New York Times he
says America finally has a pro-democracy
movement and it did very well at the
polls last week
and he talks about measures to reduce
gerrymandering and the attempts to to
finish gerrymandering okay here's the
reality
all of the laws with regard to
gerrymandering and voter ID right these
are not laws designed to disenfranchise
voters gerrymandering has always been a
contentious partisan issue it has never
prevented a party from gaining power
when there is a sweep and the the notion
that the Republicans are standing
against democracy it'll be interesting
to see how many Democrats start calling
for an end to gerrymandering now the
Democrats control an enormous number of
governorship suddenly it seems like all
of those concerns will simply go by the
wayside meanwhile Democrats also trying
to claim that the White House is is
cracking down on the model investigation
again without evidence as a New York
Times story out yesterday claiming that
the White House is trying to use Matt
Whittaker the new acting Attorney
General to crack down on the on the
Muller investigation there's not a lot
of evidence to suggest that is the case
again anonymous sources from the New
York Times as people close to mr. Trump
believe he sent mr. Whittaker to the
department in part to limit the fallout
from the Muller investigation White
House aides and other people close to
mr. Trump anticipate that mr. Whittaker
will rein in any report summarizing mr.
Miller's investigation and will not
allow the president to be subpoenaed we
should investigate by the way we should
investigate exactly what this language
means quote people close to mr. Trump
believe he sent mr. Whittaker to the
department in part to limit the fallout
from the Muller investigation one
presidential adviser said who the hell
is that presidential adviser are they
still currently working with the White
House now clear if you're an outside the
White House advisor could be Steve
Bannon who's just deciding to make
trouble for people who are still inside
the administration it could be a lot of
folks but the minute they May at
Whitaker tries to shut down the Muller
investigation he will immediately be
shut down by Congress and everybody
knows it all so it's idiotic if they
actually tried to use Matt Whitaker the
acting Attorney General to shut down the
Muller investigation come January the
Democrats are in control of Congress you
don't think that Robert Miller will be
called to testify in open testimony
about Donald Trump if that happens you
don't think it would become just another
point against Trump an impeachment
hearing on obstruction if you were to
use the acting Attorney General to shut
down the Muller investigation and I
don't believe this story at all but it's
not stopping the Democrats from claiming
that Donald Trump is on the verge of
shutting down the Muller
investigation so all the talk about
elections legitimacy and all the talk
about democracy and all the talk about
the process working as the process is
supposed to work
it is Democrats who have been
continuously claiming what the process
didn't work how it was supposed to work
in 2016 and who are claiming the
president Trump is corruptly keeping his
office now without any evidence that
that is in fact the case now all of that
is is pretty ugly and it does speak to
the radicalization of the Democratic
Party that I'm not sure Nancy Pelosi can
stave off it's kind of fascinating to
watch the Democratic Party is now split
between the moderate Nancy Pelosi wing
yes I said that phrase moderate Nancy
Pelosi wing and I say moderate not
because she's a moderate but because
compared to the intersectional coalition
about to take over the Democratic house
she's a quote-unquote moderate and the
insight so this is the battle the
intersectional coalition and Nancy
Pelosi there is a a piece by the New
York Times Cheryl gave Stolberg writing
meet the new House Democrats they may
not toe the party line she there is a
former NFL linebacker on a climate
scientist and a rapper with a Harvard
Law degree there is one immigrant from
Somalia and another from Ecuador there
are two former CIA officials an Air
Force veteran a former Navy helicopter
pilot and a retired marine commander all
of them women not to mention a
pediatrician and a human rights advocate
but these and other newly elected House
Democrats arrived in Washington for
their orientation this week they will
reflect the most diverse most female
freshman class in history the class is
ideologically diverse as well and herein
lies the problem for Democrats we're
gonna get into that problem in just one
second so the big problem for Democrats
is that their caucus is pretty fractious
half their caucus realizes that there is
severe danger in going too far to the
left that the Democrats who want
including Kyrsten Sinema in Arizona who
campaigned is much more of a moderate
than she actually is she actually
embraced the idea of sending troops down
to the border for example she refused to
come out in favor of other democratic
officials in her own State and that's
probably why she won in Arizona but
moderates won but the radicals in the
Democratic base are suggesting that they
want more radicalism more cowbell is the
answer Steve Phillips making that case
in the New York Times is do the math
moderate Democrats will not win in 2020
he says Andrew Gilliam and Stacey Abrams
progressive african-american Democratic
candidates may not have won their races
for governor in Florida and Georgia but
the
strategy they followed is still the best
strategy for Democrats to win inspiring
mobilizing and turning out voters of
color and progressive white I've argued
this strategy for years in my 2016 book
I analyzed President Barack Obama's
victories in the context of the
country's changing demographics the
implications of the Gilliam and
Abraham's races are profound and they
learn and learning the right lessons
from 2018 is key for Democrats as they
look ahead to the 2020 elections this is
over the past 20 years the
best-performing Democratic candidates
and statewide elections in Florida of
Georgia have been mr. Obama mr. Gillam
and miss Abrams this year miss Abrams
dramatically increased Democratic
turnout garnering more votes than any
other Democrat running for any office in
the history of Georgia she did turnout
heavy Democratic votes she's still lost
in Georgia if she'd been a moderate
black Democrat in Georgia then she
probably would have won she did not win
because she was not in fact a moderate
black Democrat and she was unable to
turn out enough suburban votes to bring
her victory even in an election where
the Georgia 6th swung to the Democrats
so the Democrats are in danger of
falling off a cliff with regard to their
own radicalism and that makes some sense
that makes some sense because the
Democratic base is owned lock stock and
barrel by the intersectional coalition
built by Barack Obama and there's a
coalition built by the Obamas and coming
from people like Michelle Obama Michelle
Obama is an eminently talented person
she is very charming on camera but her
mentality is an intersectional mentality
how do you know that because here's what
she said when she talked about meeting
Barack Obama for the first time she said
she was suspicious of Barack Obama
because white people liked him I have my
suspicions when a bunch of white folks
falling out over a black man because I
sort of think okay he can talk straight
so they think he's wonderful so okay I
love that she's able to say this and get
away with it imagine if there were a
white woman who said about her husband
you know I have my suspicions when a
bunch of black people love my husband
like that would be really a problem
right Michelle Obama can say that sort
of thing because of the intersectional
politics being pushed by the folks on
the left and thus intersectional
politics is actually Donald Trump's best
bet for re-election all he has to do is
make an appeal to the suburbs on the
basis of the radicalism of the Democrats
again this radicalism led by
intersectional politicians and Bernie
Sanders acolytes
like Alexandra kasnia Cortez or Andrew
Gilliam but the fact is and that
moderates
were the ones who won the key elections
across the country Democrats are turning
away from those moderates because they
believe that they can go as radical as
they want to be they may be suckered
into believing that they can run
somebody's supremely radical in 2020 and
win I don't think that that is actually
the case I think that would be a huge
mistake for Democrats to make but it is
their mistake to make
now a couple of quick notes that I think
are necessary here number one I really
don't I think because the Democratic
base is so pandering toward
intersectionality it makes it very
difficult for folks in 2020 like Kirsten
Gillibrand Kirsten Gillibrand the
senator from New York who wants to run
for president she's a deeply dishonest
politician she has shifted her positions
on everything from guns to abortion
she's done so specifically in order to
pander to a fire left base she is she's
not good at her job and she says that
she wants to run for president in 2020 I
think she has no shot at the nomination
in 2020 okay so are you staying in the
Senate or are you gonna run for
president well I'm obviously very
dedicated to serving New Yorkers but
that is a very important moral question
that I've been thinking about and I've
been thinking about it because as we
said earlier what President Trump has
been putting into this country is so
disturbing so divisive so dark that I
believe that I've been called to fight
as hard as I possibly can to restore
that moral integrity that moral decency
thinking about it Hillary Clinton 2.0
over there she ain't going to anywhere
in the primaries and everybody knows
she's going nowhere in the primaries the
folks who are going somewhere in the
primaries or the folks who gain the love
of the radical base and this is Trump's
best shot at victory is for the
Democrats to make an awful awful mistake
now he could improve that by doing a
better job reaching out to folks but you
know that necessarily president Trump's
thing so we'll talk about all that in
just a minute let's do it let's do a
couple of things that I like and then a
couple of things that I hate so things
that I like today there is a new movie
on Netflix that's kind of Braveheart
Light with Chris Pine it's called out
walking and it's about Robert Bruce and
the movie is is pretty
I would say it would be better if it had
a little bit more fleshed out character
development the best thing and it is
Aaron taylor-johnson who's a really
underrated actor you remember him from
the movie kick-ass also I think he was
the main character in 2014's Godzilla
another underrated film outlaw King is
it's pretty good
it does not cover well it basically it
covers from when William Wallace dies
and on so remember the end of Braveheart
after William Wallace is drawn and
quartered which is an unpleasant way to
go then there is the the the long shot
of the of the of the field where his
sword is and then it says that Robert
the Bruce sort of picks up the sword and
ends up winning Scotland's freedom oh
this is the movie will Robert the Bruce
basically does that here's a little bit
of the preview it tears and the soul
where's your product but it can also be
a weapon
I'm done with the running I'm sick of
hating how ice making decisions and
whatever course you are charting I
choose you my husband I will say this
the film has some of the best battle
sequences ancient battle sequences I've
ever seen I mean there's one night
battle in the forest the sequence is
pretty stunning and then there is a a
battle sequence near the end that is
that is fully spectacular I mean it's a
it's an incredible battle sequence
brutal and historically accurate the
film itself is pretty historically
accurate as well I think that it's worth
like she's very brutal I mean I will say
that this this movie is not for the
faint of heart there is a lot of blood
and there's a lot of guts and I mean
like actual guts so if that's your sort
of thing then you'll like outlaw King if
it's not then you probably will not okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
okay so first thing that I hate this is
just a terrible story a police officer
in Chicago allegedly killed a black
security guard who was holding down a
suspected shooter at a bar he worked for
according to pas moi over at Daily wire
according to The Huffington Post Jamel
Roberson 26 was working early Sunday at
Manny's blue room which is a bar in the
predominantly black Chicago suburb of
Robbins Illinois when a patron who was
part of a drunken group that had been
kicked out returned with a gun at 4:00
a.m. and opened fire several people were
shot now you normally wouldn't hear that
story because it's a Chicago shooting
only mass shootings that occur in non
Chicago are ever covered by the media
armed at the time Roberson actually did
the right thing he grabbed one of the
suspected shooters and then held him
down and waited for the police to arrive
had somebody on the ground with his knee
and his back with his gun in his back
like don't move and apparently allegedly
when the police arrived an officer with
the myth Lud Midlothian Police
Department shot Roberson who later died
at the hospital
witnesses said they did everything to
warn that confused officer of Roberson's
innocence in the ensuing chaos according
to Adam Harris is one of the witnesses
he says just waiting on the police to
get there I guess when the police got
there they probably thought he was one
of the bad guys because he had his gun
on the guy and they shot him everybody
was screaming on security he was a
security guard and they'd still did
their job and they saw a black man with
a gun and basically killed him so this
is implying that there was a racial
motive here maybe there was a racial
motive not clear at this point whether
it was racially motivated since every
a security guard and shooters were black
apparently in the situation we don't
know the race of the officer either
whatever it is this is either a tragic
mistake or negligence whatever it is
it's really bad okay obviously there are
too many police officers out there
meaning more than one who aren't ill
trained and are quick on the trigger in
bad situations and a good man just got
killed because of it and that I think
has more to do with bad police training
than it does with racism although we'll
have to wait to see all the facts of
this particular case whatever it is not
good stuff other things that I hate so
Stan Lee passed away yesterday which is
which is really sad it's never quite as
sad when somebody dies at age 95 right I
mean that in and of itself doesn't carry
the same sort of tragic way to somebody
dying before their time 95 is definitely
a full life and Stan Lee led certainly a
full life he's responsible for
spider-man the x-men Thor Iron Man Black
Panther and the Fantastic Four pretty
full career he began in the business in
1939 and he created or co-created an
enormous number of characters he's
basically responsible for the Marvel
Universe his final few years were
tumultuous according to The Hollywood
Reporter after John his wife of 69 years
died in July 2017 he sued executives at
powell entertainment a company he
founded in 2001 to develop film TV and
video game properties for a billion
dollars alleging fraud then abruptly
dropped the suit weeks later he also
sued his ex business manager so once
people get older sometimes things get
kind of rough but when he's gonna be
remembered for obviously is all the
characters that he created the more
beloved to teenagers and and adults now
across the world Marlee by the way had
no rights to the characters he helps to
create and he didn't receive any
royalties on them but he still died and
extraordinarily wealthy man obviously
his story is an all-american story he
got a job as a gofer for eight bucks a
week and Marvel's predecessor timely
comics two years later he wrote a
two-page story titled the traders
revenge that was used as a text filler
to qualify the company for the
inexpensive magazine mailing rate and he
used the name Stan Lee the pen name Stan
Lee because his actual name was Stanley
Martin Lieber so pretty pretty great
story and obviously I think everybody's
thankful to Stan Lee for the characters
he created and that we enjoy okay other
things that I hate
things that I hate um you know President
Trump decided that he would go off on
France yeah this is not a thing that I
hate it's a thing I slightly dislike I
think is fair now the president needs to
stop feeding his it's not going to
happen but he needs to stop feeding is
it if you don't want to alienate folks
then you shouldn't look like you are
responsive to every criticism the
president was criticized by Emmanuel
macron the presidents of France while
who's over in France and he could have
made a speech explaining what
nationalism is what patriotism is what
America stands for it would been a great
opportunity to do that in the aftermath
of McCrone statement instead he went on
Twitter and whined about French wine I
kid you not he said I'm trade France
makes excellent wine but so does the US
the problem is that France makes it very
hard for the u.s. to sell its minds into
France and charges big tariffs whereas
the u.s. makes it very easy for French
wines and charges very small tariffs not
fair
must change I'm fine with the idea that
France should lower its tariffs on
American wine but it's weird that the
spring to mind immediately after the
French were ripping president Trump I
mean it's just I don't think that's a
big coincidence
also he then ripped into McCrone
directly said the problem is that
emmanuel suffers from a very low
approval rating in France 26% and an
unemployment rate of almost 10% he was
just trying to get onto another subject
by the way there's no country more
nationalist than France very proud paper
and rightfully so and then he tweeted
out all caps may friends great again
number one that assumes France was that
were great but second of all the the the
tendency of the President of the United
States to go mano-a-mano with anyone who
insults him he's the president the
United States the most powerful man on
earth you don't actually need to do this
mr. president and I think that this is
not worthwhile or useful so you know
trust my suggestion
he doesn't have to he doesn't have to
take it all so he tweeted out Emmanuel
macron see just building an army to
protect Europe against the US China and
Russia but it was germinate in world's
borders 1 & 2 how did that work out for
France they were starting to learn
German in Paris before the u.s. came
along paying for NATO or not it again
I'm all for a good French joke about the
Germans but with that said you can't
simultaneously say you don't want to pay
for NATO anymore and the NATO is not in
America's interest
and that they use not in America's
interest and then be upset when the
Europeans start to form contingency
plans to defend against things like
Russia so that is what it is all right
well we will be back here tomorrow with
all the latest tonight we are in
Columbus Ohio at the Ohio State
University look forward to seeing you
there if you're in town if not you can
stream it online at yah org slash live
we'll see you then I've been Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018